this story man this is this is our this
is the weird sex stuff segment of the
day and this one
man there's sex
stuff and then there's weird sex
stuff and then there is whatever the
Washington Post is writing about in this
article Washington Post publishing a
leather mask of a donkey with chains and
spikes and stuff and a leather mask of
an elephant and says in the world of
sexual fetishes crossing the political
aisle is a
kink does a forced vote for The Other
Side get your pulse racing there is a
dominatrix for that and so I'm going to
cut out some of the more lurid details
here where they talk about all sorts of
sexual
objects and and fetishes they say a
fetish is is an inanimate object
technically say stiletto shoes a body
part feet for example or situation
required for sexual arousal though it's
frequently used interchangeably for the
broader term Kink which includes
pleasurable if unorthodox roleplaying
and you name it and these are all sorts
of fantasies well put aside those
somewhat more common fetishes and
Fantasies the new one the big one is a
political sexual
fetish guys who want their sexual
partners to make them vote for the
opposite party guys who are and this is
I assumed this was a fake thing no The
Washington Post details in in lurid
detail all these different groups online
and on various sex social media sites
thousands of people joining these groups
to say yeah I'm a liberal but I want a
republican to just call me a dumb idiot
leftist so here's just one par paragraph
This is one of the more wholesome
paragraphs and an otherwise truly
degenerate article uh he said he came up
with the idea for the group after he
received messages from a handful of
users all asking for the same thing
quote I'm liberal leftist and proud but
I really want to be dominated by a
conservative nearly all of the group
members merely want to text their
fantasies to him not act them out one
man who wanted to meet up but changed
his mind described his fantasy as
wearing a trump dog collar sold on
Trump's campaign website so apparently
that's actual Trump merch and being
walked by WR makes mites which is like
one of the users I guess around Walmart
to pick out a dog bone so I'm gonna
leave it there if you want to read the
rest of the article I got to hand it to
the Washington Post this is the single
most entertaining piece of Journalism I
have read in a very long time right now
text nolles to 2003 00 for most
homeowners window replacement is not
something they want to do but rather
something that they have to do have you
put off replacing the windows in your
home because it's too expensive then I
have great news you can now get a free
inhome window consultation and a free
quote from Renewal by Anderson Renewal
by Anderson's signature service is
committed to giving you the best
customer service possible supported by
the best people in the industry right
now Renewal by Anderson is offering a
free inhome or virtual consultation on
durable quality affordable windows or
patio doors for 0 down zero payments and
zero interest for one year I've heard
unsolicited from a carpenter who I heard
me do a read on Renewal by Anderson he
said hey I just want to let you know
when I go into a lot of homes the homes
that have used Renewal by Anderson I can
always tell right away because they have
the best Windows and I have a cousin
actually who works for the company too
and loves it text nolles kW to 200 300
for your free consultation and save 375
bucks off every window and 750 bucks off
every door these savings will not not
last long so be sure to check it out
text nwes to 2300 that is n kwes to 2300
texting privacy policy in terms and
conditions posted at text plan. us
texting enrols for recurring automated
text marketing messages messaging data
rates may apply reply stop to opt out go
to windowappointment now.com for full
offer details right now go to Ru
greens.com the holidays are here while
you at shopping for your kids family and
friends do not forget to shop for your
pets too give your dog the gift of a
healthier and happier life with Ru
greens naturopathic doctor Dennis black
the founder of Ruff greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America dog food might as well be
considered dead food since it contains
very little nutrition let Ruff greens
bring your dog's food back to life Ruff
greens is a supplement that contains all
the necessary vitamins minerals
probiotics Omega oils digestive enzymes
and antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food just sprinkle rough Greens on their
food every day dog owners everywhere are
raving about sorry excuse me are raving
about rough greens it supports healthy
joints improves bad breath boosts energy
levels and so much more we are what we
eat that goes for dogs too naturopathic
doctor Dennis black is so confident that
Ru greens will improve your dog's health
he's offering a free jump start trial
bag delivered to your door in just a few
business days go to Ruff greens.com or
call 844 ruff1 123 that is rfffg
greens.com melm AEL or call 844 r ff1
123 today it's very very funny it's
definitely revolting but the reason that
I mention it on this show is
because there clearly is a deeper
significance to this and and the deeper
significance is a lot of what the author
details as Kink or fetish right fetish
by the way the the basic meaning of that
word is is an idol so you could have a a
pagan tribe that has its fetishes
disconnected largely or totally from sex
but it's just the the idols that the
people worship and so it's applied to
all these kind of weird sex things
uh and so at that deeper level what
you're seeing is a kind of taboo what is
a taboo a taboo is a separating of
something that is that is either
extremely sacred or extremely profane or
just something you don't want to touch
it's something it's something taboo
and in our culture now the tabos are not
just some bizarre Fringe desire you ever
heard of it the tabos are political
disagreement you're not allowed to do
that anymore that's naughty it is
naughty to disagree with Joe Biden it is
naughty to have any independent
political thought it is naughty it's
shameful you got to whisper it in the
back alleys and on weird sex sites if
you in any way break from not even just
the Liberals from your political tribe
it does appear to be mostly the Liberals
here though who are signing up for this
stuff who want the conservatives to
smack them around or
something that is the sign not only of
of an unhealthy psyche that is the sign
not only of an unhealthy uh libido and
sexual desire that's the sign of an
unhealthy Society of an unhealthy
political order but of course this is
the case if you're a conservative now if
you're a pro lifer the FBI might come
knocking on your door if you're lucky
they'll knock they might just kick the
door in if you're a Catholic
the feds might be shown up to your mass
to spy on your mass to try to infiltrate
your church if you're a totally peaceful
protester on January 6 the worst day in
the history of the world you could have
a US Marshall show up to your house
arrest you throw you in solitary
confinement for voicing your questions
about an obviously very dubious
election which means
that political discourse is taboo and
for for some people that's
sexy for some people it's terrifying for
these guys it's probably both because
they appear to get a kick out of things
that are terrifying or disgusting or
revolting or broadly speaking taboo
yikes when political disagreement is
enough to titillate you and get your
rocks off because it's so naughty then
our culture is effectively no longer a
free republic that was a great clip huh
now hey you got to ring that Bell
subscribe to the YouTube channel see you
next time